[Music]
the media today I'm speaking with DWS
director-general about the media
democracy and the man himself paralimbic
welcome to the DW interview Thank You
mr. Spang great to have you with us my
name is Thomas Vaughn mr. Limburg you
have a special relationship to Germany
because you didn't grow up here your
father was a diplomat who worked in
Paris Rome Athens and Brussels what
would you say is typically german
deutsch typically german definitely the
great german cuisine which you can
always look forward to then the fact
that people abroad always associate us
with punctuality with propriety
trustworthiness maybe not very much for
a country like Germany I think in
Germany there is a sentiment of feeling
expressed by the word himat doesn't
exist anywhere else I think that's very
German that you can describe this
feeling where you come from to put a
negative spin on it there's something of
an inclination towards political
romanticism in German which doesn't
exist in other countries all I think
throughout my life much of which I spent
abroad I've always had a good view of
Germany and it doesn't hurt every now
and then to see something from the
outside rather than just the inside so I
think my life experience means I'm
well-placed to do the job I do offer
States got my novita for my job
tunicates mother I have a very German
sentence for you DW should present
Germany as a European nation of culture
and a liberal constitutional democracy
that one sentence presents a demanding
task that is DW is broadcasting mandate
how do you do that in practical terms
feed into a central government with a
lot of interesting programs I think the
most important task that the lawmakers
have given us is to inform that's our
most important duty
in Formula One soir we have to inform
people especially when there might not
be sufficient knowledge about Germany or
Europe people aren't allowed to discuss
in their own regions of the world
because they're censored there DW has a
huge duty to provide freedom of
information and then there's the entire
set of values that we also have to
impart the liberal constitutional
democracy that DW represents in which it
propagates is crumbling in Poland
Hungary Russia Turkey
how does DW reacts these developments we
try to refer especially to the issues in
those places where we have a broadcast
presence in Turkey in Russia and in
Poland we try to inform our users
listeners or viewers and give them the
outside perspective we can't tell anyone
what they should think that's not our
duty and we always have to ensure that
we manage to remain available to a wide
target audience but we can guarantee
freedom of information and also point
out that democratic rights aren't a
luxury or negotiable in the EU for
example when there's a growing number of
people who don't consider democratic
rights to be that important who wants
security does that mean DW the voice of
democracy is talking at cross-purposes
for more and more people no I don't
think so I think for us also in
countries where democracy is in danger
and there is a real lack of freedom is
to be there for those who do believe in
democracy
history has shown us that whether in
Poland or Greece during times of a
dictatorship the DW played an
outstanding role as the voice of freedom
perhaps we are only accessible there for
a limited time and only for a minority
simply because not everyone can access
our services
but we want to offer that minority
support so that people in countries
where democracy is at risk you can see
there are people on the outside who care
about them we're not really there yet in
Poland and other parts of Europe it's
important to us that we don't point a
warning finger at them but continue to
demonstrate the merits of democracy
before to the Democrats you know Vida
want to watch their right-wing populism
is on the rise in Germany as well the
AFD party is entering parliaments what
can journalists do to bring these angry
citizens back to the fold
I don't believe that it's d-double news
job to confront the Germans in Germany
with topic matter in any way our main
task is clearly to address overseas
audiences but we do believe it makes
sense for our programming in English
Arabic and Spanish to be made available
in Germany as well in order to build a
bridge between different nations and
languages in Sweden
I think that the unrest in Germany and
the rise of right-wing populism is
something that's happening across Europe
we're no exception it is nevertheless
dangerous when these political parties
try to chip away at democracy when they
don't just express themselves in a
so-called nationalist manner but when
they stray from the basic principles of
democracy it becomes dangerous and the
job of the media is to identify that and
to make every instance of it public and
not to capitulate or stay silent or
accept the fact that someone is
attacking democracy democracy otherwise
that's good and that also applies to the
US where right-wing populism is in
charge
DW awarded a prize for defending Press
Freedom to the White House
Correspondents Association in Washington
do you believe press freedom is in more
danger in the US
than in Russia or China for example
non-decision no certainly not the u.s.
is a great democracy which has shown
that it can overcome many challenges
naturally we hope that it will overcome
the current ones but it seldom occurs
that the head of state in an established
democracy questions democratic rights
and that includes freedom of the press
which is a prerequisite for democracy
and that is extraordinary and that's
when we say we have to highlight events
there as well and show that we don't
just focus all our attention on the
southern hemisphere Russia whether we
focus on everywhere where press freedom
is threatened in the u.s. that is partly
the case right now Donald Trump taking
issue with you for that prize send you
an angry tweet no he did not and he
doesn't have to I think Donald Trump's
tweets speak for themselves and we need
no further exchange there that kind of
the fact that Donald Trump also governs
by tweeting is a sign I think of a
turning point in communication generally
social media is becoming increasingly
important for journalists as well as
being able to reach people through the
existing channels in a competitive
market do you think it's to your
advantage that your DWS first Director
General with a commercial TV background
does just include traveling home on
commercial TV background perhaps gives
me a broader overview of the market and
target audiences does that mean a better
eye for the ratings that rule commercial
TV yeah yes that means that the issue of
reaching a wide audience is more of a
focal point now although reach isn't
everything we have to be able to make an
impact we need quality journalism that
means we don't do things just for the
ratings
we wouldn't put on a new entertainment
show to appeal to more people or show
funny cat videos
no we focus on producing high-quality
journalistic content that will connect
more to people but of course without
reach that is irrelevant once you came
under criticism at DW because you made
cuts to the news coverage on the German
Channel
can you imagine France 24 Frances
international broadcaster only
broadcasting the news in English no but
they do broadcast in English and are
beginning in Spanish but also in French
of course France 24 continues to
broadcast in French but you have to take
into account that we have a German
language TV channel to which is received
worldwide and unlike the French we don't
have such a large community of German
speakers but we continue to broadcast in
German and we are glad to do that and we
still have a new show and short news
shows but it's true that we have made
adjustments and are focusing more on
cultural programmes than in the past
it's Dhaka quick to a hunger water to
the motto strengthening the English
language programming and cutting back
the German one is part of the aim to try
to bring DW on par with BBC and CNN
isn't that as somewhat daredevil it's
not to say hopeless aim these
broadcasters have twice the budget and
only broadcast in English the BBC
broadcasts in other languages of course
and I think that's our benchmark that's
why I think it is worthwhile to aim high
that goal isn't impossible to reach we
will reach this goal in many countries
and in many languages being one of the
top three foreign broadcasters and
that's why I think it was right to set
ourselves this target and we're well on
the way to achieving that to round off
our interview we always like to put
forward three unfinished sentences and
ask our guests to finish them so from my
father the diplomat
Peter Lindbergh senior I learned the
smothered you need an open view of the
world without prejudice and to act
wisely by crookedy insulting the fact
the signs channel cut my reporting on
the election of a new pope in 2013
before the new pope appeared was
inappropriate not the most clever
decision by my former employer who I
otherwise have a lot to thank for and
holding great esteem probably wouldn't
happen at TWU its director-general I am
not obliged to like German music but my
favorite would be German music is back
and Rammstein mr. Tambourine thanks for
talking to me you're welcome